thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode hey crazies everybody loves
Saturn am I right just look at this
thing it's Majestic but it's not
actually the only planet with rings
Jupiter Uranus and Neptune have them too
they're just harder to see where do
these planetary rings come from how long
will they last and why doesn't Earth
have rings because frankly that would be
Wicked awesome
[Music]
as with most stories it seems natural to
start this at the beginning no no we
talked about this it's way too far back
I mean the beginning of planetary Rings
OMG I suppose this is what I get for not
being specific enough let's go back to
when planetary Rings were first
discovered
to the timeline the first observations
of rings came in 1610 when Galileo
pointed his telescope at Saturn as you
can see from his sketch he didn't know
they were Rings Galileo thought they
were giant moons but like a good
scientist he kept observing by 1612 his
giant moons had completely disappeared
from view this wasn't too suspicious
though those moons could have easily
moved behind Saturn in reality he was
looking at the Ring's Edge on but he
didn't know that thankfully he got a
better look a few years later in 1616 he
drew another sketch that makes Saturn
look like it has handles or ears we
wouldn't actually figure out they were
Rings until Christian Hawkins looked at
Saturn in 1655. the faint rings of the
other three gas giants are much more
recent discoveries
1977-79 and 84 respectively Jupiter's
rings are so faint we didn't discover
them until the Voyager space probe flew
by
does that mean only gas giants have
rings oh no we've actually found dwarf
planets with rings really yep there's no
reason a rocky planet like Earth
couldn't have rings huh in fact in the
next 30 to 50 million years we expect
Mars's Moon Phobos to become ranks so
rings come from moons yes and comets and
asteroids sometimes there's a whole list
of ways rings can form ring stability
depends more on where they form
back to the timeline we've been trying
to figure out planetary Rings since we
first discovered them but progress
wouldn't be made until 1848 when eduar
Roche published what we now call the
Roche limit it's a critical distance
from a planet inside which other objects
break apart and form Rings Earth's Moon
became a Moon instead of rings because
it Formed outside that limit billions of
years ago a mars-sized object collided
with Earth launching Earth material out
into space this material was still
gravitationally bound to Earth but more
so to itself which allowed it to
coalesce into the moon if that material
hadn't been launched as far it would
have formed Rings instead and we can
predict where that limit is sure
approximately let's consider a real life
example I mentioned earlier Mars's Moon
Phobos was going to turn into rings
soonish if this is Phobos then Mars
should be right about here
Phobos is Tiny by comparison so I'm
going to exaggerate sizes for clarity
which is something I've never ever done
before
anyway with the size of Phobos
exaggerated we can see the source of its
inevitable demise according to Newton's
Laws gravity depends on distance we see
here that some of phobos's mass is
closer to Mars and some of it is farther
away that means gravity is not uniformly
distributed across Phobos it's stronger
in some places and weaker in others the
total amount of force doesn't actually
matter though only the tidal forces
matter that's how different each arrow
is from the arrow at the center we're
using the center gravity as a reference
for all the others so while all the
gravities point toward Mars not all the
tidal forces do it makes sense now why
Phobos is going to break apart so then
why don't all moons break apart because
tidal forces aren't the only forces
involved it can be a bit overwhelming to
look at all these forces at the same
time
so consider a single tiny Rock sitting
on the surface of Phobos let's say on
the side facing Mars This Rock has a
tidal force on it pulling up toward Mars
but that's not the only force acting on
the Rock if this was the only Force The
Rock would lift off the surface and
drift toward Mars we know that's not
happening so there must be some other
force overpowering it like maybe the
Gravity from Phobos itself that moon has
mass so it has self-gravity that's the
gravity between its parts it's what
Phobos and any other large object uses
to hold itself together for our single
rock that looks like this it has a tidal
Force up a gravity down and a push up
from the ground to keep things balanced
at the moment that downward gravity is
bigger than the tidal Force so the rock
stays put but that won't always be the
case the orbit of Phobos is gradually
decaying as it gets closer to Mars the
tidal force will increase while its
self-gravity stays the same eventually
it's gonna it close enough that the
tidal Force overpowers gravity that rock
is going to lift off the surface and
since that rock is just a placeholder
for all the rocks that make up Phobos
the entire moon will come apart
the distance at which that occurs is
called the Roche limit and it looks
something like this it only depends on
the mass of the planet the mass of the
Moon and the size of the moon
technically though this version is
called the rigid Roche limit because it
assumes the Moon is perfectly rigid
unfortunately assuming the Moon is
perfectly rigid is a bit of a stretch
pun intended so Roche himself went a
little further he assumed a moon
destined to become Rings would stretch
out a bit before actually breaking this
only changes the coefficient out front
giving us the fluid Roche limit if
deformation is allowed the roast limit
is actually larger wait wait the moon
breaks up sooner if it isn't rigid yeah
it blew my mind too when I first learned
it as it turns out the deformation
increases the tidal forces thereby
causing more deformation which increases
the tidal forces even more it's a
positive feedback loop of course both
the rigid and fluid models make one
giant assumption that a moon is just a
clump of tiny rocks held together by
gravity which might seem kind of silly
when you first think about it but it's
actually a decent approximation most of
the time particularly with some of the
more massive moons and asteroids you
really only need to account for
molecular forces in a couple situations
artificial satellites in the ISS are
well within their own Roche limits yet
they survive because they're too small
for Gravity to be what holds them
together also some materials like ice
are kind of sticky that's why Comet
Lovejoy was able to survive back in 2011
even though the comet was inside its own
Roche limit with the Sun but most of the
time this equation works pretty well a
realistic object will break apart
somewhere between these two limits
for Earth's Moon that's between about
one and a half and three Earth radii
Which is less than five percent the
total distance to the Moon that means
the Moon is quite safe and if it hadn't
been launched that far it would have
formed Rings instead of a moon but those
Rings would have been long gone by now
why well planetary rings are temporary
the orbits are unstable so those tiny
bits of rock and Ice gradually fall into
the planet data from the Cassini Mission
show Saturn's rings are only about 10 to
100 million years old and our current
estimates predict they'll only be around
for another 100 million years or so plus
Saturn has a couple larger moons inside
the ring system keeping the Rings in
line so they're especially long lasting
Earth's Rings would have collapsed into
Earth long before life even evolved here
no human would have ever seen views like
this for Earth to have rings now we
would need a more recent cataclysmic
event but you really want a Majora's
Mask situation on your hands I certainly
don't creepy AF anyway planetary rings
are the result of a larger object
getting too close to a planet outside
the Roche limit we get moons inside the
Roche limit we get ranks because tidal
forces can be and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
if you want to learn more about tidal
forces brilliant.org can help their
gravitational Physics course starts by
introducing Newton's law of gravity and
then later applying that law to real
world situations like ocean tides for
example you're not just memorizing
formulas and equations though brilliant
is designed to build your intuition the
idea is that when you see a problem
you'll have the tools to solve it
yourself brilliant has thousands of
interactive lessons on many different
topics foundational math advanced math
data science neural networks and more
with new lessons added monthly brilliant
was built for busy people with
bite-sized lessons that break down
important Concepts into understandable
Parts they have physics puzzles too if
you feel like you've learned enough for
a challenge to try everything brilliant
has to offer free for 30 days go to
brilliant.org science Asylum or click
the link in the description below the
first 200 of you will get 20 off
Brilliance annual premium subscription
it'll also let brilliant know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
there were a lot of people appreciating
our talk on Quantum field Theory and
wanting more no worries there will be
more I'm finally learning qft myself so
you'll get a video every time I know
enough to make one there's a lot to
learn though anyway thanks for watching